Daenerys Targaryen has been on quite a
journey throughout Game of Thrones and
thus anyone's guess where she winds up
at the end of season eights some of
those guesses though some more plausible
than others here's a look at some
Daenerys fun theories that just might
come true
i'ma show you something real special the
script of the final season of Game of
Thrones perhaps the most complex theory
about Daenerys is that she will not only
die but will actually become a white
Walker and it will be Jon Snow that
kills her
this theory hinges on the legend of the
ancient warrior azor Ahai who has been
prophesized to return one day to save
the world in author George RR Martin's
Song of Fire and Ice book series which
the show is based on it said that azor
Ahai Foster's famous flaming sword
Lightbringer by plunging it into the
heart of his beloved wife and Nissa
Nissa some fans sing that john is azor
Ahai reborn and that to reforge light
bringer he will need to killed on a
burning sword from the fire and that
sword shall be Lightbringer making this
theory even more complicated it's the
idea that Dany will then write as a
white Walker just as her dragon
previously rose from the dead this is
based on another ancient legend from the
book about a long ago Commander of the
Nights Watch who married a corpse bride
some fans sing that these two legends
are actually won on the same and that
Nissa Nissa was the corpse bride so if
John is azor Ahai reborn wielding a
sword of fire and Daenerys is Nissa
Nissa reborn reigning as a white Walker
the two together will make up the Song
of Ice and Fire
that gives the book series its title hey
we told you it was complex speaking of
prophecies from the book there's another
one that didn't make it into the show
but could still prove crucial at one
point Daenerys is told that she will be
betrayed three times once for gold once
for blood and once for love two of these
have already happened in the show so
draw a Mormon betrayed her to King
Robert for gold or the which Meera Mazda
betrayed her for blood so some funds see
rise that it will be Tyrion who betrays
her for love
some say for love of his family others
suggest for his own Umrah quieted love
of Daenerys
say it ain't so Tyrion so back to that
whole azor Ahai thing many characters in
the series believe azor Ahai is a
subject
another prophecy called the prince that
was promised which foretells a rebirth
of an ancient hero who will save the
world
Melisandre the red priestess is a big
fan of assuming any random Schmo is a
prince I was promised first declaring it
to be Stannis and later assuming as
actually Jon Snow but one theory
originally espoused on the books but a
Night's Watch Maester Aemon Targaryen is
the idea that Daenerys has actually the
prophesied hero
it turns out the original prophecy was
in the ancient language high Valyrian
which is genderless meaning it could
actually refer to a princess just as
easily as a prince one of the most
explosive revelations of thrones'
seventh season was a reveal that Jon
Snow's name isn't John Snow at all it's
Aegon Targaryen and he's not Ned Stark's
lowborn bastard but a member of the most
royal family in all of Westeros born to
Ned sister Lyanna Stark the man
audiences knowest Jon Snow is a son of
Rhaegar Targaryen making him the
rightful heir to the Iron Throne and the
Narus his nephew John isn't really my
father's son he's the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen and my aunt Lyanna Stark some
funds expect this to be a major point of
contention even leading to John and
Daenerys battling each other for the
Iron Throne
let's hope it doesn't come to that ever
since audiences met Daenerys Targaryen
they've been prepared to accept her as
one of the show's heroes but what if
she's actually the ultimate villain
there's precedent of course as the whole
reason her family was to pose in the
first place is because the Mad King
Aerys went on a literal reign of terror
burning people alive at the slightest
whim just as Dany begun doing in season
seven in particular the Mad King
threatened to destroy all of King's
Landing
that's something Daenerys seems poised
to do before the series end though she
won't need wildfire to do it a
confrontation with archenemy Cersei
Lannister who currently sits on the Iron
Throne seems inevitable
and since League step photos seem to
show King's Landing in a state of
destruction it looks as though Dany and
her dragons may finally finish with the
Mad King promised
whether or not she completes her he'll
turn in the process to become a true
desperate remains to be seen Daenerys
says journey began with a political
marriage and some fancier eyes her
journey will end the same way in order
to solidify her claim to the Iron Throne
a
ethical marriage to jon snow or even
Jaime Lannister makes some sense
still some sentimental fans theorize
that Dany will actually marry Sir Jorah
before he's forced to kill her and then
die himself trying to stop the night
king okay maybe they aren't so
sentimental
this is just one of several fun theories
are also believed Daenerys will become
pregnant with John's child and that the
series will end with their offspring set
to inherit the Iron Throne
hey at least somebody in that scenario
would have a happy ending and like a
final fun theory which suggests that
daddy might actually die at the
beginning of the season and we'll never
even have a chance to do any of that
stuff
eagle-eyed fans compiling reports from
the various filming locations around the
globe
reported that while nearly every single
other character of note appeared for
filming Emilia Clarke who placed an
heiress did not leading some to conclude
that her carats I must die early before
as locations come into play hey you know
what they say Valar morghulis
I don't want gorlice Valar morghulis yes
all men must die but we are not to man
check out one of our newest videos right
there plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]